I hate to follow Seinfeld at The Comedy
Store toughest follow I ever had in my
entire life oh I'm sure dude because all
he did was talk about how Mitzi the
owner oh that's right I told him he
wasn't funny the last time he was there
he's just right you were there for that
set crushing he buried me with a shovel
nothing like it ever because he's
telling them the whole story so even if
the people didn't know how big of a deal
it was that Seinfeld was in the or The
Comedy Store he told them this lady told
me I wasn't funny I wonder how she's
doing now all this stuff I bought a
house above her house so that she could
see me driving a different car all the
time I'd beep as I went by still not
funny I mean he's destroying destroying
he's like evil cool [__]